Rishi sunak and his wife akshata Marti
arrive in in Tokyo hoping to cement his
growing status
on the international stage the pm at a
naval base this morning greeted with
Pomp and a parade which rose
to the occasion a show of military might
protecting peace in this region their
priority to counter an increasingly
unpredictable China
the UK signing a defense agreement with
Japan with the aim of strengthening
security economic and technological ties
we're increasing our engagement in the
region to work with allies like
Australia like Japan to ensure that the
Pacific region does remain free and open
we don't want to see any change to the
status quo by force or coercion this
region is going to be increasingly
important to our economic prospects at
home if you look at where Global growth
is going to come from Over the coming
decades the indo-pacific region is going
to be increasingly important important
because Money Matters to people back
home this afternoon the PM mingling with
businesses celebrating Japanese
investment for jobs in the UK I'm
delighted to announce new investment
commitments worth nearly 18 billion
pounds this is a huge vote of confidence
in the UK economy and with that the
Whistle Stop tour continued on to
Hiroshima as the G7 leaders assembled
the mood one of optimism determination
and unity but the geopolitical Outlook
Bleak war in Ukraine a rogue Russia and
Rising aggression from China these
allies have plenty of problems and the
task here in Hiroshima this weekend is
to not just show a united front but a
preparedness for action too
tonight Mr sunac meeting his Japanese
counterpart sporting socks featuring p.m
kashida's favorite baseball team a small
gesture but with big intent this a
relationship a region of growing
importance and where much is at stake
bath Rigby Sky News in Hiroshima Japan